hey 42 here about 2 300 years ago
in syracuse sicily free old lady sat on
a bench in the town square
it was a warm mediterranean day and they
chatted about this and that
as old ladies on park benches do
suddenly loud shouts of
i've got it i've got it broke through
the morning air
the women looked across the square to
see a young man running towards them at
high speed
as he got closer they realized he was
stark naked
you certainly have got it thought the
first old lady to herself
then she had a stroke the second old
lady
also had a stroke the third old lady
almost had a stroke too
but her arms were too short the crazy
streaker who ran through town
that day was archimedes the celebrated
physicist
mathematician astronomer inventor
engineer and exhibitionist and the
reason he was shouting
eureka or i've got it was not because he
wanted
the world to know he had a large package
but because he just solved a nagging
physics problem only a few minutes
before
archimedes had been climbing into the
bath as he did so he noticed a water
level rising
and had a sudden flash of insight or
as it subsequently became known a eureka
moment
in that instant of clarity archimedes
understood the principle of displacement
and realized he'd found a way to measure
the volume of a gold crown
and by extension its density
the crown in question belongs to the
king of syracuse
who suspecting his goldsmith of cheating
him
wanted archimedes to devise a way to
test
whether the crown had been made of solid
gold as required
or gold mixed with silver
by dividing the mass of the crown by the
volume of water displaced
archimedes was able to determine the
crown's density
and since it was lower than it should
have been
proved the goldsmith was a lying
you've probably had a few eureka moments
yourself
i know i have just yesterday i thought
of a word that rhymes with orange
i'll tell you another time even though
they don't have bad hair or
sing 80s norwegian pop eureka moments
are
also known as aha moments but
regardless of what you may call them
they have delivered some of humankind's
most radical breakthroughs
the theory of gravity dawned on isaac
newton
as he watched apples fall from a tree
albert einstein finally distilled the
theory of general relativity
whilst riding on a tram august cooley
saw the chemical structure of benzene
as he nodded off in front of a fire
arthur frye
fought up the post-it note in church
exactly how this process works has
always been a bit of a mystery
the eureka moment is similar to the type
of divine inspiration
artists yearn for it's unpredictable
and can't be manufactured but
neuroscientists studying inside have
discovered that strokes of genius
have a very clear signal in the brain
and can be encouraged by creating
just the right neurological conditions
it all comes down to brain waves but
before i get into the amazing science of
brain waves
i want to tell you another way you can
release your inner genius
by watching curiositystream who've
kindly sponsored this video
curiosity stream is home to thousands of
incredible documentaries
and other non-fiction films and tv shows
with award-winning exclusives and
original shows
on everything from history to science
technology
travel food and much more whatever it is
you want to learn about
you'll find it it's smart tv
for your smart tv and you can watch it
on any device
anywhere at any time i love learning
and if you're like me you probably found
the documentary and
non-fiction offering on other streaming
services
disappointing i know i have so i was
genuinely amazed to discover curiosity
stream because now i know there's always
something new for me to watch
whenever i get the opportunity i
particularly enjoy old architecture so
i really enjoyed watching history's
greatest homes
especially the episode on hampton court
palace one of my favorite historic
residences
click the link in the description and
use code 40 to sign up today
for just 14.99 for the whole year
brain waves are the product of the
brain's electrochemical function
that big mass of grey matter in your
skull contains billions of neurons
nerve cells that receive and send
electrical signals throughout the body
on average each individual neuron
connects to
thousands of others and they communicate
through small electrical currents
that travel along the neurons and
throughout enormous networks of brain
circuits
when neurons are activated and
synchronized
they produce electrical pulses and the
rhythm of these pulses forms
oscillations called brain waves and
when many neurons interact in this way
at the same time
the activity is so strong that it can be
detected
even outside the brain by placing
electrodes on the scalp
the brain activity can be measured
amplified
and visualized this is
electroencephalography
or eeg it's what neuroscientists say
when they mean
brain graph like most waveforms brain
waves are generally measured in terms of
their amplitude or depth
and their frequency which describes the
number of oscillations in a given period
of time
to make things easier there are five
main brainwave patterns
categorized according to their frequency
and then to make things more difficult
again
these patterns are named after letters
of the greek alphabet
gamma beta alpha theta and
delta on its own that's about as
interesting as saying there are seven
colours of the rainbow but what really
started to blow neuroscience's hair
back as they studied these phenomena was
the realization that different brain
waves
are connected with different brain
states
feeling calm and relaxed there's a brain
wave for that
or are you feeling alert and focused
there's a brain wave for that too
brain waves don't cause your state of
mind but
waves and states are correlated take
gamma waves for example widely regarded
as the fastest waves produced by the
brain with a frequency of 26
to 100 hertz they're quite rare
tend to have a high impact for a short
amount of time and are associated with
episodes of heightened perception
insight and intuition mark beamon a
neuroscientist at northwestern
university
and john cunios of drexel university
pioneered research into the eureka
moment using
fmri and eeg machines with this
technology
they were able to study the brainwave
patterns of people trying to solve
puzzles
and discovered that about a third of a
second
before a person has a sudden flash of
understanding
the brain sees a massive spike of gamma
wave activity
for archimedes that flash of insight was
followed by a flash of his balls
but it turns out that's an unusual
reaction a beamon
and cuneos also found a burst of slower
alpha waves
i'll tell you more about those in a
minute over the right visual cortex
an area of the brain that controls our
sight just
before the flash of gamma waves this may
be because the brain
is calming the neurons in that area to
reduce the
amount of visual data being taken in to
free up more resources for the more
important cognition tasks
that's why you often close your eyes or
look away when concentrating on a
question
before the answer pops into your head
gamma waves disappear during anesthesia
suggesting
they have some sort of connection to
consciousness itself
this idea has been implied by other
research too professor of psychology and
psychiatry richard davidson
has conducted extensive experiments with
olympic level meditators
such as buddhist monks who have an
average lifetime experience of more than
000 meditation hours that's almost four
years of solid meditation
he found that rather than having brief
and sudden experiences of gamma
brainwaves like most people do
these meditators had an almost permanent
condition
of prominent gamma wave activity
davidson also discovered that when the
test subjects were asked to meditate on
certain things like
compassion gamma wave levels jumped
seven or eight hundred percent
for mere mortals like you and i though
gamma brain activity is likely to stay
inconsistent reserved for moments of
genius
like the time i invented a new kind of
sandwich with the bread on the inside
what we are far more familiar with
though is beta brainwaves
occurring in the 13 to 32 hertz
frequency range
beta waves are associated with our
normal waking state
and suggest alertness and active
thinking beta waves are present when
we're focused on a task
engaged in conversation trying to solve
a problem
or making a decision it's the brainwave
pattern that's usually present when
we're busy and thinking of a hundred
different things
you know normal life slightly slower
than beta waves in the 8 to 13 hertz
range
we find alpha waves these were the first
brain waves to be discovered
and occur when we're physically or
mentally relaxed they're often connected
with higher levels of serotonin one of
the feel good hormones
and are frequently present during
episodes of artistic
creativity awareness and light
meditation
a step below alpha waves we start to
enter
slow brainwave territory feta waves are
thought to be between four
and eight hertz and naturally occur when
we're daydreaming
falling asleep or in rem sleep
they're also found when people are in
deep meditation or
doing something that allows the brain to
go into autopilot
like brushing your teeth research has
also shown a positive association
between
feta waves and memory creativity
and psychological well-being finally the
slowest waves conventionally recognized
are delta waves found between 0.5
and 4 hertz they're strongest when we're
in a deep
dreamless sleep the time during the
night that our brain and body are
dedicated
to rejuvenation your brain needs to
spend time in this state to repair
itself from
social media the kardashians politics
and all the other stuff you put it
through on a daily basis
but as this field of research expands
some claim to have found fringe
brainwave frequencies
like epsilon waves that oscillate
between half a cycle a second
and as low as one quarter cycle every 10
seconds
these super slow frequencies were
theorized after studying yogi's
and long time meditators and they're
fought to accompany the
controversial yogic state of suspended
animation
in which the practitioner has no
discernible pulse or breathing
so basically dead but apparently also
not
dead like a zombie things get weirder
still when you look at lambda brainwaves
these are extremely fast frequencies
almost twice as fast as gamma waves at
about 200 hertz
so they're at the opposite end of the
spectrum from the absurdly slow
epsilon waves or are they apparently
if you zoom in really really far into an
epsilon wave
you can see high frequency oscillations
of lambda waves
riding the epsilon wave so
waves within waves like inception
but whilst you're awake no wonder lambda
waves are fought to be connected with
transcendental states and out of body
experiences
just thinking about them melts my brain
for now
all this talk about epsilon and lambda
is pretty meaningless
they're extremely difficult to measure
and unlike the five
primary brainwave patterns there is very
little scientific data to support any
clear conclusions
in fact you may be asking yourself what
is the use of all this brainwave mumbo
jumbo anyway why should i care what
frequency my thoughts are surfing at
well the science and technology used to
measure brain waves
can also be used to reverse engineer the
brain states associated with
those wave patterns remember those monks
who achieved
advanced mind states and showed almost
constant
gamma brain waves they achieved that
through training their brains
even though they had little interest in
brainwaves
and now neurofeedback tools are able to
show people their brainwaves
in real time helping them train their
minds by
changing their brainwave patterns and
finding
optimal states of consciousness
technologies like binaural beats
claim to use audio frequencies to
stimulate certain brainwave patterns
encouraging your mind to experience an
associated state so
for example listening to an alpha
brainwave track
might encourage your brain to
synchronize with the alpha rhythm
tricking your mind into thinking you're
tanning on a beach in bali
brain waves only reflect underlying mind
states and
behaviors they don't cause them but
the thinking goes if we're able to
influence our brainwave patterns
we're influencing our mental states too
possibly
allowing us to choose which mental state
we operate in the ability to change your
mind state at will to meet the needs of
whatever situation you're in
would be a bit like having a superpower
and the potential here goes beyond just
you a growing body of research shows we
can influence each other's mental states
too
one study conducted by the basque center
on cognition brain and language
reveals that the rhythms of brain waves
between two people taking part in a
conversation
begin to match each other in separate
research princeton university
neuroscientist
yuri hassan has shown that the stronger
the connection between two people
the more their brains click they
literally
get on the same wavelength another study
in new york suggested that brains of
people in the same group
tend to all be in sync making them like
each other more
and further enjoy the experiences they
share together
of course someone had to come up with a
name for all of this
so they've decided to call it
interactive social neuroscience
it's a new field so there's still a lot
to understand but it has the potential
to show what happens neurologically when
we behave a certain way
or connect with other people with that
information
and a lot of practice who knows perhaps
you could not only master your own mind
but also the minds of others too
basically you could become yoda
only taller and that's pretty cool
thanks for watching and thanks again to
curiositystream for sponsoring this
video